hey guys it's day 25 of quarantine in
our house like you we're binge-watching
tiger king stress-baking and less fun
experiencing a reduction in our income
we realize we're in an incredibly
fortunate position being able to write
it out without making significant
sacrifices but that is not the case for
most as we've mentioned before 40% of
Americans can't pay for a $400 emergency
without credit even if you're not facing
a Corona induced cash crisis yet that
doesn't mean you're out of the woods the
economic fallout from this disaster is
going to have an effect on your life no
matter what industry you're in
unfortunately like this virus anxiety is
also contagious so it's only natural
that a lot of us are asking ourselves
the same question how do I survive a
financial storm your first step needs to
be to create an emergency budget yep if
you haven't yet climbed on board the
$0.02 budget train 2020 is the perfect
time to start
first rule of emergency budgeting is it
must be written or typed out not in your
head so find a spreadsheet or sign up
for a budgeting software some are
completely free second step is to gather
data from the past that way you're
working with real numbers and not the
amount you think you spend start by
looking at the last two months were the
transactions and make a list of
everything you spend money on this might
take a little time but hey for a lot of
us time seems more plentiful than ever
start by grouping the essential expenses
at the top housing the utilities basic
groceries transportation and medical
needs second list debt payments like
student loans or credit card minimums
finally list all of your discretionary
expenses like entertainment meal
delivery and subscriptions what you're
looking at is your pre-crisis budget now
it's time to use that data to draft your
emergency budget your first draft should
take on a scorched-earth
field by cutting everything below your
minimum debt payments Spotify why post
dates
even Netflix feels pretty bleak right
don't worry we're not done now it's time
to create a second draft where you
strategically pick discretionary items
to add back in this might just be one
thing like Netflix or if your income
took a less drastic hit you can add back
three or four things it might come as a
surprise but holding on to a couple of
tiny splurge items might actually help
you more in the long run than cutting
them completely one survey showed over
half of Americans owned up to
impulsively shopping as a result of
feelings of anxiety stress and
depression an 83% of those stress
spenders regret those purchases later
for example I find a lot of relief in
being able to play a few online games so
I'd rather maintain access to that
outlet and cut out ordering in because I
find cooking less stressful you might
have a different preference the point is
that you need to give the pressure
cooker a small but intentional release
that way you're less likely to make a
massive impulse by later now that most
of your discretionary spending is paused
it's time to try and slim down the
expenses that make up the majority of
your needs your essentials and with
almost 7 million applying for
unemployment just last week lenders and
utility companies are being especially
lenient if you own a home with a
mortgage and have had your income go
down reach out to your mortgage company
immediately to discuss options the two
mortgage giants Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac are rolling out relief measures to
help millions of homeowners defer or
rework their loan payments even
institutions like Chase Bank of America
and Wells Fargo are all coming out with
their own offerings and while landlords
are less regulated than mortgage lenders
they also might be able to extend you
more time or even be a little more
flexible on terms but again you need to
ask your next round of calls should be
to your utility companies and insurance
providers many are offering to give
their customers leeway to skip or delay
payments as you work your way down your
list of bills you'll finally get to your
minimum loan payments thankfully all
federal student loan payments have been
suspended
a recent stimulus bill until September
30th and even private lenders are
offering forbearance programs you should
also reach out to your credit card
companies and any other lenders on your
list they're all joining the less people
can pay s party the one thing that most
of these forms of relief have in common
is that benefits are not automatic you
have to reach out and ask them for help
proactivity is the name of the game and
even if they don't let you skip a
payment they might have the power to not
let it affect your credit score that
alone would be worth the call and if you
already have cash set aside or are
expecting some in the form of say a
stimulus check from local Sam you should
keep that on hand to cover your expenses
your income can't well it might be
tempting to pay off debt or even invest
with a recent stock market drop cash is
king in a crisis even if your income is
only somewhat hit its best use is to
plump up that emergency fund a bit more
just in case Murphy's Law decides to
show up
and even with flexible payments and
forbearance plans coming online we see
many folks considering extreme measures
like taking on five figures of credit
card debt yanking from retirement or
even ignoring bills entirely is there a
time and a place to take these drastic
steps maybe but they should be an
absolute last resort we definitely don't
recommend taking our credit cards or
loans if you have cash you can access
that's exactly what it's for you truly
need to be living the scorched-earth
lifestyle in earnest before resorting to
those tools and if you're in survival
mode and debt is not an option
prioritize paying for your basic food
utilities and transportation you'd need
to keep yourself employable if you still
have leftover funds move on to your
housing costs and minimum debt payments
the main reason putting your utilities
before your housing costs make sense is
that the consequences set in more
quickly and
giving housing payment there's no way to
sugarcoat it it's an especially scary
time but it doesn't have to be an
unmitigated disaster don't allow panic
or shame to take complete control you
have the power to make a plan and reach
out for help and that's our two cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
patron
[Music]